Scandal now is that there are text
messages that are being leaked out
there's audio recordings being leaked
out the job that Hunter Biden had in the
first place as this consultant for
Ukrainian Energy company when we know
money was being filtered to him and now
going up to his dad it's all sort of
leaking out right now so what the media
did last week was they were uncover
right oh let's get him on some tax
evasion stuff that'll hopefully get
everybody to stop talking about it
here's White House spokesman John Kirby
and this guy what's with this guy's suit
I feel like he's wearing what did you
say you said it looked like three dogs
like in a suit something's going on with
this guy's suit here he is clashing with
a reporter over the hunter Biden text
messages
house Ways and Means Committee yesterday
released documents their authenticity
nowhere challenge
that included a July 2017 WhatsApp
message set by Hunter Biden to Henry
Zhao a Chinese Communist Party official
does this not undermine
the president's claim during the 2020
campaign that he never once discussed
his son's overseas business dealings
with him no and I'm not going to comment
further on this
James James let me just let me save you
some let me say let me say let me save
you some breath if you're going to ask
about this I am not addressed I don't I
know you do more than I'd like you to
have I am not going to address this
issue from this Podium I'm just not
going to do it all right I'm not going
to do it
thanks guys have a great weekend
okay guys I'm not going to talk about
that thing I'm wearing a very puffy suit
up here what do you want me to do I
can't talk about that thing do you
remember I mean we've played the clip
for you many times where Hunter uh where
Joe Biden is like I've never discussed
business with my son ever which on its
face is just complete nonsense is there
any is there literally anyone alive
today who has any remote relationship
with their father
that is no idea what I do we have never
discussed the work he doesn't know why
I'm working for this Ukrainian Energy
company there's texts that are now
proving it right and there was a
voicemail by the way that leaked that
has proved it like it's just but Kirby
Democrat privilege right you get to wear
your big suit and I'm not going to
answer that question I gotta go here's
our diversity hire
thank you
[Music]